[Music]
hi entertaining tonight I'm Jennifer
Lopez and you're on the set of Selena
welcome
[Music]
I'll be playing you haven't figured it
out Selena it's been 20 years since
Jennifer Lopez skyrocketed to fame
playing the late AHA no singer in Selena
file pageant wave and only et was behind
the scenes of the 1996 set there's just
so many aspects of the world there's the
accent there's the singing and dancing
she was such an incredible performer
I'm not a thing I haven't performed as a
singer so I'm a dancer I'd be singing in
the might be over here yeah yeah yeah oh
the mic yeah because it's not really
super voice and I just think of my own
life you know and how things are
starting to roll for me now and doing
all this move and I don't have time to
do anything and you know besides exactly
what I do
the role earned Lopez her first Golden
Globe nomination was a driving force
behind her own singing career and has
left a lasting impression on the
performer two decades later I honestly
believe it was God's sent me that role
for a reason so I could learn from her
so I could always have her as an
inspiration just it was a great lesson
to know that you know you're not
promised tomorrow and you have to you
have to love and live for today
[Music]